president Trump framed the midterms as a
referendum on his presidency the results
could shape how both he and the
Democratic Party positioned themselves
for the 2020 presidential election
Susan pages of Washington bureau chief
for USA Today she is covered every
midterm election since 1982 good morning
to you Susan page hey good morning Gail
so let's talk about last night was it a
referendum on his presidency number one
and does it set the sager how does it
set the stage for 2020 starting with the
president yeah absolutely I think this
was a report card for Donald Trump and
he got kind of a split decision right I
mean if you look at Republican states he
really showed his control his command of
the Republican Party in a big way helped
some of those pickups for for
Republicans in the Senate but if you
look at those House races and especially
in suburban districts you really saw a
different kind of judgment on how
President Trump is doing so it doesn't
just set the landscape for 2020 2020 is
underway president Trump has been
running for 2020 since the day he was
inaugurated and the rallies that we saw
with this one were about helping
Republican candidates on the ballot this
year they were also about helping him in
two years and he has transformed the
Republican Party the chairman of the
Republican Party was strongly defending
his ad that many people John Kasich Jeff
Flake and others said was a straight-up
racist ad so if the challenge for a
president is whether they get a primary
challenge it seems like last night and
his complete sort of control over the
Republican Party means he's in very good
shape in terms of any kind of primary
challenge in his own party he may get
one but but he's got a real relationship
with those primary voters you know he
may get a primary challenge there are
still Republicans who don't support
President Trump but he's not going to be
deposed from the head of the Republican
Party this is his Republican Party is a
different Republican Party than the one
that existed before he ran for president
and you look at the people you name to
are critical of President Trump there
are people who are we're not on the
ballot they're people who decided not to
run in the Trump Republican Party and if
you look at the handful of Republicans
who were on the ballot who distance
themselves from President Trump a
congressman and
Florida congressman in Texas they lost
last night did we get any more clarity
last night as to who the Democratic
opponent would be that the president
would run against in 2020 I don't think
that we I think that this is a wide-open
race one of the most wide-open races in
modern times for the Democratic
nomination and one other heritage from
President Trump is if he demonstrated
you don't need the traditional
credentials of a presidential candidate
to win the nomination and even win the
White House so that is a message that
we're hearing so not only kind of the
candidates you'd expect like Joe Biden
for instance and Bernie Sanders who won
last night Elizabeth Warren we're gonna
see I think a much bigger field of that
will include mayors and former cabinet
members we see running for president
even people who lost last night like
beta better or Roark in Texas or being
talked about as potential contenders for
this nomination we talked all night
about change in Congress but there's
gonna be change in president trunks
cabinet in the coming week how will that
affect his his presidency yes I think
we're gonna see a wholesale change in on
some White House staffers and in the
cabinet in particular some of that is
natural after two years people get tired
but this has been a presidency that has
unprecedented turnover in those top jobs
some people have lost the president's
confidence I wouldn't be surprised if we
saw changes in the Attorney General and
some some people are just ready to move
on good news for the president that he
got to bolster the Republican margin in
the Senate that will help him win
confirmation for some of these new
people and quickly Susan how do you see
the president working with the
democrat-controlled Congress or is he
gonna pick new fights are they gonna
have some kumbaya moments you know I
asked the president about that when I
interviewed him about two weeks ago and
he's insisted that he could work with a
Democratic controlled house and with
Nancy Pelosi to work on of course the
default issue we always talk about is
infrastructure maybe they'll make a deal
there but this is going to be a very
contentious time because one thing we
know is going to happen investigations
left and right as soon as Democrats take
control of the house in January and the
president also says one thing and does
another frequently Susan Paige thank you
so much